[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
my
do
[Music]
welcome i'm angela galvan i have been
with the table since 2018.
we're so glad you're with us today i
have two announcements that are both
great ways to to get connected at the
table
the first is the state of the table
meeting which is held at 6 15 pm
next sunday august 23rd this is a chance
for you to get the inside scoop on the
table
from the internal discussions we've been
having on staying online
versus meeting in person to a review of
the budget
the vision for the rest of the year and
how you can get involved
if you care about the table as a church
community then you'll want to join us
next is the men's support group led by
daryl adams
which meets every tuesday at 7 pm
if you'd like more information we'll
post daryl's email in the comments
as we transition to worship i wanted to
share a poem written by gary miner
that captures the kind of community we
are here at the table
we are the bold ones the ones who don't
fear to challenge the status quo
our thoughtfulness matters our curiosity
is beautiful a collage of friendship
love heartbreak and disappointment
it's okay it's okay to be different
let's agree that it's okay to disagree
let's celebrate that we don't stand on
the same side of every issue
yet let us support encourage and lift
each other up as brother and sister
come sit eat listen
talk cry laugh and be
sh be still
breathe hear the rhythm of your own
heartbeat
tune into god's spirit breathe him in
be filled up and be poured out
be fragile be bold be meek
be strong seek the uncomfortable ways
where god leads
and don't worry what others say rise up
praise him be not afraid
hi table friends so uh before i do this
song i wanted to talk to you about
um a phrase that's getting used a lot
these days
it's called the new normal
i'm sure most of you if not all of you
have heard it and probably
probably used it um
language is kind of a a tricky thing
because
we use it every day we we don't
necessarily
we don't really think about what we're
saying and we can do a lot of good with
the words that we say
and we can also do a lot of harm with
the things that we say
and uh catch phrases you know are also
kind of you know people start using
catch phrases they um
they don't really think about what
they're saying you know it is what it is
a dime a dozen
uh the new normal i think
is a particularly dangerous phrase that
we use
because when we call something normal
and let's not even talk about what
normal is because that's a different
discussion but when we call something
normal it's like we're saying it's
okay and i've heard the new the phrase
the new normal used a lot this year
for a lot of different things and
there's just some things that i'm just
not okay with
um and that's been weighing heavy on me
the last uh last couple weeks a lot and
um
you know it's almost like there's a
magnifying glass with the uh with the
pandemic
you know where you know we can see the
cracks
clearer than we could before and uh
yeah so i've been i've been uh you know
struggling with uh
a lot of things the last couple weeks my
my
go-to verse whenever i'm i'm for
years of my life uh has been john 16
verse 33
and these when jesus says these things i
have spoken to you
that in me you may have peace in the
world you will have tribulation
but be of good cheer i have overcome the
world
and the hope that we have in jesus is
just a it's a marvelous thing
and uh that's what this song is about
it's it's called face to face and it's
about
it's about a time when walls stand with
jesus face to face
and and all the pain and uh and all the
sickness and
and the walls to divide us will be gone
and uh and we will all together stand uh
as one face to face and uh and that my
friends that
is a new normal that i'll be willing to
[Music]
embrace
oh i'm a traveler
[Music]
so far from home
and i get lost
but i press on
cause that's the mansion in streets of
gold
[Music]
where we belong
yeah there's a day
coming soon
where the old
[Music]
will be made new
[Applause]
and heaven's glory she shines like the
morning
before i rise
[Applause]
when we all
see jesus
see jesus yeah
no more sickness
no more sadness
no more pain
when we all
[Applause]
see jesus
face and faith
then we will sing
with angel's voices
there will be great
[Music]
great rejoicing
holy holy worldly worthy
is the lamb
when we all
see jesus
when we
no more sickness no
more madness
no more pain
[Music]
when we all
[Applause]
see jesus yeah will we all
[Music]
see jesus
when we all
[Applause]
see jesus
[Music]
face
thanks carter yeah i'm going to kind of
keep it
i guess bluesy or soulful um i got a
different song as well
this one's called cross that made the
change and if you have heard some of the
stuff we've been doing around here at
the table we
steal a lot from um oh my gosh
my brain is blanking um
common hymnal thank you yes brain
so yeah i hope you enjoy this one
[Music]
um
when they saw jesus
he saw a teenage mother
they saw an unbelieving brother
just a man in poverty
but when i see jesus
i see the sovereign and a savior
i see the healer of the nations
i see the stone roll away
nobody thought that this son
of sorrows would be broken for
love to fix our tomorrows
but it's the cross that made the change
it's the cross that made the change
i'll let everybody know
is the crossing made the change
[Music]
when they saw jesus
they saw a rebel and a problem
they did everything to stop him
even put them on a tree yes they did
but when i see jesus
i see the servant and the savior
i see the healer of the nations
i see the glory from galilee
[Music]
and nobody thought that this son
of sorrows would be broken for love
to fix our tomorrows
and nobody thought that this son
of sorrows could be broken for
love to fix our tomorrows
but it's the cross that made the change
it's across made the change
and i'll let everybody know
it's across and made the change
it's the cross it made the change
it's the cross that made the change
and i'll let everybody know
it's the cross and made the change
now when we see jesus
we become like jesus
but we know how he sees us
we will never be the same
now when we see jesus
we become like jesus
where we know how he sees us
we will never be the same
[Music]
mr cross who made the change
i'll let everybody know
it's across and made the change
it's the cross that made the
[Music]
it's change cross that made the
change it's the
cross that made the change
well i hope you guys enjoyed that song
and um
before we get started with the message
i'd like to just take a moment to
pray um so if you would bow your heads
with me
close your eyes and um i'm gonna try to
play as i pray at the same time so
pray for me yeah it's gonna be
interesting
all right yeah father god
we thank you for this time together
[Music]
we had you fill us with your spirit
help us to tune into you lord
[Music]
help us to breathe you in
i pray for brett lord god i pray you
lift him up
i pray you give him boldness as he
speaks
what's on his heart
and i pray that you open our hearts and
our minds our ears
[Music]
and i hope that each one of us would
find something
[Music]
something that's challenging something
that's
um true for each one
something that brings conviction
so father god we love you we thank you
that we can be together
[Music]
it's in your name i pray lord
amen
[Music]
well thank you um gary i thought you
you played and prayed real nice that's
awesome
um and thank you to uh carter and
angela as well this is lovely and i
think that was
angela's first time if i'm not mistaken
to um
kind of do our opening welcome so great
job my friend
um so good evening grace and peace uh
welcome to the table
uh for those who don't know i think i
might have seen a few visitors joining
us my name is brett
and it's really wonderful just to be
with you all
um and especially if you're new to the
community welcome so
our our vision here at the table as the
poem at the intro
kind of um hinted at that uh our vision
is to shift a generation
from reactionary to visionary through
the person and work
of jesus and we of course live
well we're in a bit of a crisis as a
culture so we live in a reactionary time
you know crisis and stress
um just tend to put us in a reactive
rather than a kind of more reflective or
proactive
um place you know we get in a state of
heart and mind
where we just easily become our worst
selves
um rather than the beautiful best self
the christ-like self
the true self that god is inviting us to
become and so
when i think of the table i think of a
group of people um
not who have already attained such
things i came across a line
this week in um a book i love it's by
len yutang it's called the importance of
living
um he was a chinese i think i want to
say maybe
i don't know if he was actually
chinese-american his parents i think he
was raised quite a bit in the west he
spent a lot of time in the west he's
riding like a
maybe you know 80 years ago or more
maybe 100. um but he has a line where
he's talking about um
tao i don't know if you know anything
about um the tao or or
taoism but there's a line where someone
is kind of like talking about god
but there's a line where um the the
writer he's translating lin newton is
translating someone else's work
and the line is uh i have not
attained the tao uh i am merely one who
loves it
and i was thinking of that you know my
relationship with with god
um and that's kind of who we are at the
table you know we're not people who have
who claim to have attained you know
union with god
uh or perfect christ-likeness likeness
we are merely people who love it
and so when i think of the table and
people here i just think of people who
are on that positive path
together you know learning to be our
best selves
and hopefully um the message this
evening
um just you know takes us like a few
steps in
in that general direction so we are in
uh part nine
of our series on the gospel of luke and
the title of my message
is mustard seeds and today we're going
to be in luke
chapter 17 verses 5 through 10.
so now before we jump into that this
passage it talks a whole lot about
faith so i want to just define that term
right up front
so faith is a belief in trust in god
now that might be a bit kind of
oversimplified because of course the
term faith in the bible it's a
very kind of historical term it's a rich
term lots of shades of meaning and such
but you know sometimes simple is better
so let's just roll with that faith is a
belief and a trust in god
uh when i say trust in god i'm thinking
you know a trust in his goodness
um a trust in his love that's that's
what faith's about
so all right with that in mind let's go
ahead and read these words
uh these are the words of christ uh
beginning in verse five
the apostle said to the lord increase
our faith and he jesus replied
if you have faith as small as a mustard
seed
you can say to this mulberry tree
be uprooted and planted in the sea and
it
will obey you
verse 7 suppose one of you has a servant
plowing or looking after the sheep
will he say to the servant when he comes
in from the field come along now and
let's sit down to eat
when he rather say prepare my supper get
yourself ready and wait on me while i
eat and drink
after that you may eat and drink
will he thank the servant because he did
what he was told to do
verse 10 so you also when you've done
everything you were told to do
should say we are unworthy servants
we have only done our
duty so growing up uh i have this
very kind of distinct memory
of my family being on vacation somewhere
and
you know it's like one of those days
where you travel all day and then you
finally get to the hotel
and i mean i was you know like young
maybe 10 or so so i was just very
excited to be
at the hotel and of course you know the
cool thing about the hotel is like you
have the television right in your room
that was very fancy back in the day we
didn't have you know screens we just
carried around so
uh so we had to like kick back on the
bed i remember i just turned on like the
television
and uh there was some religious
christian
programming on and as i recall
it was someone named jimmy swaggart
uh and some of you may remember this guy
um
what i remember is that he kept talking
about
faith faith faith just over and over
you gotta you gotta have the faith more
faith you gotta
increase your faith your your faith is
too small if only you have the faith
uh and then he's i mean it was very
extravagant he's like if only you have
the faith
then you won't be sick anymore if only
you have faith
you won't have money problems anymore if
only you have faith then that promotion
at work i mean that's as
good as yours but if you find yourself
lacking faith
well he had a solution uh for a donation
of it was something like 50
i just remember it being very
unreasonably high
uh 50 he would send you this is no joke
a piece of
carpet
oh christianity not the whole thing just
parts wings of the family are just i
don't even know are they in the family
that's
it's heretical it's it's crazy uh so
he's literally he's selling his prayer
carpet and he held up
a piece in his hand it was like a small
square and he said these
are portions of my prayer carpet
and they are anointed
and the ridiculous idea seemed to be
that he was you know of course a great
man of faith
and so i guess somehow his faith could
enter into the
fibers of those carpets and then
transfer to you
or something something that affect and
uh even at like 10 years old
i smelled a rat i was like
i don't know about this uh so fast
forward a few years
i'm now a teenager and i was like in
this youth group
with other christian teens and i
remember someone was sick
and the other students wanted me to pray
for them
and thankfully the sickness was kind of
internal so it would be a bit vague as
to whether or not they'd been healed
immediately
but i was very nervous and as i go
to place my hands on them
i remember this internal dialogue like
starts running through my
mind and it went something like this
uh oh no i don't
i don't think i have the faith for this
and this other voice was in my head like
brad you're fine
you're fine like yes you do god can use
you and i'm like no
no he can't yes yes he can no no he
can't and i
i remember licking my lips nervously and
i closed my eyes very tight
and with passion in my voice i prayed
for healing and
i think though looking back on it i
think the passion
was trying to convey a certain
confidence
you know i was overcompensating i was
trying to portray a confidence a trust
of faith that i wasn't really sure i had
kind of like uh maybe like a man
mostly men not i mean it could be mostly
dudes that buy a very large truck
um that they cannot afford to compensate
for their own insecurities uh i
would that was me with my boisterousness
and passion i was hollering at the devil
and every spirit of sickness from here
to oklahoma and
uh i mean i you know at least i was
trying to portray a lot of faith
even though on the inside i was very
nervous and at the end i remember the
person said they felt a little better
but i think they were probably just
trying to be nice
so i guess i lacked the faith
which is why i can certainly relate to
the disciples demand
when they pray lord increase our faith
because you know in a lot of circles
faith is
the thing i mean it's it's the thing
we're slightly obsessed with
and uh when it comes to faith the key
question in many of our minds
is like how high and how deep and how
long and how wide is your faith
and this is why with the disciples we
oftentimes
pray maybe you've prayed a prayer like
this like god i just need the faith lord
increase my faith please because the
idea
is that we lack faith right that we need
more of it we we think that um you might
say
faith is to life as gasoline is
to an engine you know you always need
more
and woe to you who runs out woe
to you who lacks the faith and so this
is why we we pray lord you give me
more faith i just don't have enough
faith and this is why we can experience
guilt
uh when for example i mean it could be
over a lot of things but
when say like a loved one is sick and we
pray to god but they do not get better
and we wonder you know perhaps i
i lacked the faith this is why we look
at others
and how great their lives are going
i mean they just seem to be natural born
believers uh but our lives are not going
so well
our kids don't act as good we don't make
the same money
our families are more dysfunctional and
so
that in that internal voice it just
starts
whispering in our minds it's a lack of
faith
right we don't we don't have enough
faith gasoline in our life engine
and so our our little lives sputter
and choke and backfire their way
embarrassingly
uh down the street um
you know just making us and our families
kind of look
bad the whole way and then we come to
church and of course
in passages like this we're only
reminded
that if we really had the faith why we
could be superheroes
tossing trees into oceans and such
don't question whether or not that's
awesome trust me if you saw someone
with only their mind and faith pick up a
tree and fling it across the road
you'd be very impressed uh but here's
kind of my question for tonight
um what if we've radically misunderstood
this passage
what if just like the disciples we have
made this assumption
that it really is about the quantity
the size the depth the amount
of our faith that's like the main thing
which is why we worry just like the
disciples did that we
lack faith and it's why we pray things
like lord give me more faith increase
my faith because we think
that's our primary problem and and
that's also why for years i mean frankly
i read this passage and i took it as
basically jesus just flat out shaming
the disciples
um i mean because they're you know
they're effectively saying i don't have
enough faith and he's saying
yeah no kidding you don't like you're
pitiful
why if you had even a speck of faith you
could do tremendous miracles
but where are your miracles have you
ever done marvelous things disciples
no no you have not which tells me you
don't even have a mustard seed of faith
i mean if you had even a drop of faith
in your spiritual gas tank your life
would be amazing
but your life's not amazing and that
tells me you don't even have a drop
a speck a mustard seed of faith i'm not
angry i imagine jesus saying
just disappointed which is usually
something people say when they're angry
but as i look back at this passage again
and and actually start to read it more
in line
with the love and the character of
christ
in mind i begin to get a very different
picture because yes i mean there are
places in the gospels where jesus
chastises the disciples for a lack of
faith but then
even then like his message isn't
you need huge faith more faith
world-changing faith his message
is always i mean almost the opposite
like hey
just show a little trust which as i look
at this passage makes me wonder if
perhaps i've completely misread it
in other words i don't think jesus is
saying you're right yep you need more
faith instead by his statement
that with only a mustard seed of faith a
a speck a wisp
of faith that you can do amazing
things i think he's saying my friends
you already have all
but you already have all the faith you
need in other words
the prayer lord increase my faith deep
in my faith stretch my faith
it's the wrong prayer it's not the issue
as maggie said a few weeks ago in her
message it's it's an
adventure and missing the point
so here's kind of what i'm driving at i
think that
living well is
not about the size or quantity of my
faith
but the extent of my faithfulness
let me say it again living well is not
about the size or the quantity of my
faith which is where we focus right
we're all about the i just i need more
you know
but but what if it's not about that what
if it's actually about the extent
of our faithfulness think of it uh like
this
faith gets you to the starting line
faithfulness determines how well
you run i mean at one level or another
i think we um we all sort of have to
live
as though god is and as though there is
some truth and goodness
in the world we all have to aim our
lives at something
like some transcendent value we have to
center on some
ideal we all have to trust
well that's faith and thus to be
christian right is to have that
faith not just centered on some abstract
ideal
or you know something but it's to be
centered on christ right faith in
christ but that's just the starting line
and and frankly i really i don't care
how much faith it takes you to get to
the starting line
because the point is that you're there
i've stood on a number of starting lines
for various races in my life
and you can often tell by looking at
people's eyes how much faith they have
for that race
some people look very bold and confident
uh you know they're ready
and others they look like they're about
to puke
um and yet they're all there right
they're all on the starting line
they've all trained uh and by the way
it's not about
how like awesome and in shape they look
necessarily i mean i've seen people that
look very prepared but the look on their
faith
says you mean they're strong but their
face says i'm about to vomit
uh and so i think actually right the
point is that they're all in the
starting line
they've all trained so at that point the
question
uh is not how much faith do you have for
the race
it's instead it's how faithful
will they be to the race right how well
will they run and by the way i think
this is why jesus
immediately goes from talking about
mustard seeds in the passage we just
read
to a faithful servant notice
it's not a faith-filled servant
right we're all trying to be
faith-filled people
uh when it seems that god is actually
more interested
in faithful people
and i don't think uh that this really
should surprise us because when it comes
to other key relationships in our lives
uh whether it's it could be marriage
work you know friendship um
aren't we really all looking for
faithful people i mean it's really nice
like for example if a friend were to
come up to you and say oh man i have so
much
faith for this friendship like it just i
can't tell you how much it means to me
and i know man i just
know in my bones like man we're gonna
make it
like i just know 30 40 years from now
we're gonna be sitting on a porch
sipping whiskey
reminiscing together about the good old
days i just got so much faith for that
um okay i mean that's great and all but
honestly what's that they say about talk
talk is cheap but it's not talk or faith
or just sheer belief
that's going to get us to that porch my
friend what's it going to be
faithfulness commitment
um now perhaps there is a certain danger
in i mean i don't want to make it sound
like i think you know faith is nothing
or even like some sort of problem that
is not the case let me be really clear
that's not the case like i said it faith
matters it gets us to the starting line
of life it gets us to the starting line
of our relationship with god
um of learning to be like jesus like it
gets us to the starting line
i mean to trust that god is as good as
is
as good as jesus has revealed him to be
uh that takes faith but again
like you're here tonight logging online
i'm assuming you have you have the faith
you need
the question is how can we be more
faithful how can we be more
faithful um i think that's the question
and so let me go ahead and give you
i don't have like lots of points tonight
i want to give you just one practical
suggestion
um and this is something i've kind of
been i've mentioned this in the past
but i think it fits really nicely in
this context and we forget it so so
easily
uh so here's here's my insight focus
less on the outcome
and more on the process see we tend to
get
very focused on outcomes
on the on the happy ending
and on avoiding the the
unhappy ending right we get kind of
obsessed
there like saying at least in kind of a
positive sense like boy i just can't
wait
until you know x happens
man just wait till all this hard work
pays off and i'll arrive at goal y
uh or z you know just just imagine it
success uh how sweet it will be
and actually um
you know this now that's the positive
version but we also do this
the negative version right uh which is
oh my gosh i don't i don't know if i
have faith for this
i don't i don't know i don't know if i
can make it
what if what if i'm not strong enough
what if what if i
fail what what if my life comes crashing
down around me what if
what if people laugh at me what if what
if i'm faced with a situation i simply
don't have the strength
the faith in god to handle uh and
honestly these you know examples
um this is both for my own life and
emotions i've experienced in the last
six months as well as a lot of
conversations with with many of you you
know this is the things i'm hearing is a
lot of this
and you can see what's happening right
we're getting very um
focused on the outcome and and there's a
lot of
fear that we we lack the faith the
strength the resilience the resolve
the trust the belief in god you know to
to make it
and i think honestly like just coming
back to
this passage and following christ i
think a lot of that is it's
kind of a waste of energy um i mean
first off it's pretty clear
that faith in the bible is not something
you you actually drum up
either through inspirational self
pep talks like i can do it i can do it
uh nor is it drilled into us by fear
you know if you lack the faith you will
fail no uh
and besides the whole time we're like
playing these games with ourselves
um what are we missing what are we
missing when we spend so much time
focused on the outcomes dreaming about
wishing for it hoping we get it
worrying that we won't anxious that it
won't work out like what are we missing
here's what we're missing
the actual well we're missing our lives
right like the actual steps of
the journey that get us
where god is calling us to go
aka faithfulness
all right and this is what i'm driving
at what if what if we've been so
obsessed with our
faith whatever that exactly means like
this idea of getting
more faith or drumming up faith creating
faith praying for faith like
what if we're so obsessed there that
we're
completely missing the point jesus says
well honestly you just need a mustard
seed like
if you've ever seen a mustard seed i
mean i thought of holding one up but you
wouldn't be able to see it
it's like a speck right so he's saying
oh no all you need is like that
just a little trust and then what's it
about after that
faithfulness the actual steps
of the journey that get us where god is
calling
us to go so so stop worrying
about your lack of faith and start
doing engaging the daily steps of
faithfulness
that will be required of you and this
applies to i mean just almost anything
right you if for example you want to
become a person of prayer
um stop asking for more faith
just stop and just start praying like
just just start doing it right or or you
want to get
through whatever personal
hell you are in the midst of and i know
many of you well and we have got some
people going through hell
um stop worrying about whether or not
you have the faith to do that
and you just focus on the next
wisest most faithful
action you can take
um every other day i have this this
habit where i i go on a run
and it's um and part of that run is is
up a hill in my neighborhood now we're
in texas so you know i mean
it's not that bad but it's oh it's up
and and the thing is it's one of those
it's a long one it's it's a little over
a quarter of a mile
and it comes in the last mile of of my
my three mile run and so i have found
uh during this um run this is a little
pro tip
the worst thing you can do
is stare at the top of that hill
that is especially when it's 100 degrees
outside
um or today 102 i think we wanted to
uh yeah don't because what happens when
i do that
uh the only thing coming to my mind is
why why isn't it getting
that's closer it feels like i'm not even
moving right now uh no that is the wrong
strategy right instead
the best thing we can do is look 10 feet
in front of us
and focus there just the next step as i
said a few was it maybe
six weeks ago now um keep your world
small
yes same sermon different context keep
your world small like
that's all we need to be worried about
the next
wisest most faithful action and this is
this is a recurrent theme
uh in my messages because in the age of
kovid
and an economy that is uh not good
and huge question marks just over all of
our futures
the worst thing we can do is begin
staring
at the top of our hills and
in beginning to fret over whether or not
we have the
faith to make it to the top
uh stop no it's it's not about that it's
not about the
the extent the size the amount of your
faith
it is about your faithfulness
and when we focus there god can do
miracles with us
and we just might find ourselves tossing
proverbial mulberry trees left and right
that no one thought we could ever move
and when at the end of our days uh we
closed our eyes for the last time
we can rest knowing that as jesus said
uh he closed it in verse 10
as faithful servants we have done
our duty can i pray for you lord jesus
um
we ask for faithfulness but i'm trusting
that every person
who's hearing my voice right now
whether they have just a mustard seed of
faith
or um something even more than that
god that no matter where they're at i
trust that it's
enough and that you're gonna take them
from where they
are and you're going to do amazing
things
lord so keep us faithful fill us with
your spirit
lord empower us to stay on the path
to love well to be wise
and we trust that you're going to carry
us through this
we trust that the faith we have is
enough be with us
empower us carry us into this week and
may we not just survive may we thrive
god
in the life-changing name of jesus i
pray amen
thanks brett um as i listen to
that message the thought that goes
through my head is
there's not much that can happen with
the faith that we have
until we give it over and allow
god to do things with it or trust that
he will do things with it
so this week as i was thinking through
that a couple of songs came to my mind
songs that may not typically go together
but
if you know me i'm gonna find a way
so i hope you guys will enjoy this
mashup and um let it be a prayer for our
lives
as we give over what we have to god and
let him do
what we can't do on our own
take my life
and let it be
[Music]
consecrated
lord to thee take my moment
in my days
let them flow in ceaseless
let them flowing
take my hands and let them
move
[Music]
take my feet and let them be
swift and beautiful for
thee swift and beautiful
take my silver
and my gold
not a might
[Music]
thou shalt
we can entertain compassion
in a world of need of care
but the road of good intentions
doesn't lead to anywhere
cause love is in love
till you give it away
there was a man who walked on water
he came to set the people free
he was the ultimate example of what love
could really be
cause love wants his life
and he gave it away
[Music]
yeah he gave it away
you gotta give it away
we gotta give it away
take my love my lord i
pour at thy
feet it's forever yours
take myself
and i will be
[Music]
oh for thee
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are in need of prayer or
support in this time
please send the table a facebook message
or email us
on our website also to all of you who
support the table financially
thank you your gifts empower us to carry
on this work
for those who would like to support us
you can do that on our website
at thetabletx.org
don't forget about the state of the
table meeting next sunday
after the service and our men's group
meeting this tuesday night
all right let me send you with it into
your week with this blessing
the grace of the lord jesus christ and
the love of god
and the fellowship of the holy spirit be
with you all
hope to see you back here next week
you